ever since our phenomenal vaccine
program began last winter
we've been in a race
a race between the vaccine
and the virus
and although we're ahead in that race
the gap is narrowing
we've come so far thanks to the efforts
of so many
but with winter ahead
we can't blow it now
so we're going to do everything we can
to maintain our lead by strengthening
our vaccination program as our primary
line of defense
first
we'll redouble our efforts to encourage
anyone who's eligible
to take up the initial offer of a jab
there's almost 5 million people over the
age of 16 that remain unvaccinated in
the uk
it might be someone you know a friend a
family member a colleague
and if you do tell them
that it's never too late to come forward
so if you yet haven't had your job
please take this huge step
to protect yourself and to protect your
loved ones
second
we've extended the offer of a vaccine to
more and more people including young
people aged between 12 and 15 years
and we'll be making it easier for them
to get protected by opening up our
national booking service so they can get
their job at a vaccination centers
across the country as well as at school
third
we've also started rolling out our
booster program
which is vital to keeping us safe over
the coming months
because
although our vaccines offer powerful
protection
we now know that the protection that you
get from a coveted vaccine reduces
materially over time
especially in older people who are the
greatest risk
and without delivering a top-up of
protection through a booster dose
we will see a real-world impact
as well as this
covered 19 mutates like any virus
and we're identifying new variants all
the time
this includes a new version of the delta
variant which is currently known as a y
4.2
and that new variant is now spreading
and while there's no reason to believe
at this point that ay 4.2 poses a
greater threat
the next variant
or the one after that
might do